gods and be us
the envious because we're mortal
because any moment might be our last
everything's more beautiful
because we're doomed in history they can
only ever be one the moniker of the
strongest is something passed down from
Titan to Titan something only a very
talented and blessed individual is
capable of achieving hard work and
determination means nothing at the basis
of how you build your strength is shaky
to begin with luckily for saturu Gojo
his infinite potential is built upon a
ground far stronger than that of a
stolen child's corpse having completely
annihilated agito who he didn't see his
fit to belong in his presence it is said
that with Gojo having also landed a
second black flash his intensity
increased and as he felt a rush of
exhilaration flow through him he
activated his reverse curse technique
allowing him to comfortably heal that
previously failed arm on the other hand
and for the first time in 1 000 years
the king of curses ryoming sakuna
finally begins to feel the weight of
battle reignite in the fight godro stuns
everyone as he lands his third black
flash but this time on maharaga does him
back hitting Texarkana by surprise as he
appears directly in front of him saguna
tries to throw a fat right hook but Gojo
comfortably Dodges it and grabs the king
of piss's hand before adjusting his
polarity and throwing him into mummy
maharaka not giving him a moment to
relax as well Gojo follows up with his
fourth black flash luckily for sakona
maharaga was able to block the strike
with the sword of extermination still
the impact from Gojo's punch smashed the
wall behind him and sent them sliding
back through one floor of an office
building floating outside that seat
office building Gojo raises his hand and
begins chanting in preparation for his
next technique phase preparation pillars
of light and Jujutsu a spark as the
curse energy that swells up inside a
sorcerer just before they go and
activate a technique and the moments
before a domain activation short hit
technique and other powerful abilities
there will be without exception a spark
even the great Gojo with his immense
curse energy isn't an exception to this
rule this fact doesn't change instead
it's all the more obvious for his Holo
technique purple inside of the building
and based on the encantations that was
said by Gojo along with his scale of
curse energy put into those said
incantations sukuna believes that this
spark currently before his eyes was that
of the curse technique reversal red
so what's a kona's plans are in
preparation for the attack as to have
maharaga Tankard then on top of that
adapt to Red to put Gojo in his place
however sukuna's judgment on this next
attack was by no means incorrect
activating curse technique reversal read
Gojo blasts his ability straight upwards
into the sky completely confusing
tsukona as he obviously thought he was
going to shoot it at him after a second
thought though he quickly comes to
realize the magnitude of what's
happening and calls forth maharaga
blasting up through the levels of the
building maharaga shatters each window
as he speed of his movement and creases
in an attempt to catch Gojo's read
moments after red was fired sukuna
figured thereby merging the lapse of
blue and the reversal of red Hollow
technique purple is formed produce an
imaginary mass that Russians forth
shooting itself outside of the building
now it's shown they're just ahead of
maharaga the red Gojo had previously
fired was headed directly at the
perpetuated technique that had crushed
the ghetto earlier blue in a general
sense the technique red falls into a
standstill but before it will explode
sakuna was able to figure this out
because of the ability Gojo used on him
last time you know when he gave him the
fat back shots maharaga was sent up by
him to prevent the abilities from
merging firstly what's a Kona had
planned for the shikigami to do was to
attack blue and completely erase it as
it like had already adapted to Blue
beforehand all that ran through the
beast's mind as it tried to do this was
a yearning to fulfill orders traveling
up at a rapid speed though and using the
attractive force of his own blue satsuru
Gojo flung himself between his blue and
maharaga blue chooses its targets
without bias and because its attraction
is an effect in the adapted maharaga as
a side effect it causes adaption to
actually backfire plunging fourth goju
lands a fat uppercut on the shikigami
that leaves sukuna with no one to defend
him as he prepares his own last ditch
attack pulling up his hands to perform
another use of his piercing blood like
ability shakuna plans to disrupt
emerging by causing the explosion of red
first before it can merge Susie offers
ability Gojo quickly follows up and
punches the king of curses in his side
looking up and seeing the disability was
able to shoot forth and that it was
about to clash with gojos sakuna
confidently remarked that he was too
slow unfazed by this all Gojo quickly
rattles off the Incarnation for blue
FaZe Twilight eyes of pranja and such a
short period of time that an utterly
stunned sakona glancing at his attack
again he watches as it passes into
Gojo's steadily merging technique not
affecting it in the slight Hurst the
reason that it didn't actually disrupt
red right there is because gochu in
those last like milliseconds before the
uh technique was about to hurt
reactivated and restored his outpod
following the incarnations that he just
previously said which is actually insane
when you think about it like I don't
even know how men did that anyway
floating there with both foes on each
side of him Gojo starts his incantations
for the legendary Hollow technique
purple nine ropes polarized light Crow
and shomio the gap between within and
without when it's in the Battle of this
Century back at the TV room Yuda
apologizes to kuzakabe for what he had
said previously as to him it's pretty
obvious that if a burden searches
himself into the battle then Gojo
wouldn't have been able to do this with
both colors fully combining and the
purple light of the Gods themselves
getting even brighter Gojo looks upon
both of his terrified opponents faces
and finishes the incantation purple
instantly following the implosion of the
two techniques an imaginary force of
Unstoppable curse energy exploded
outwards destroying maharaga along with
anything and its path and completely
burying all of Shinjuku under a carpeted
layer of rebar and Rubble Barefoot and
barely able to stand now sukuna having
survived the blast holds himself up
against a broken wall in front of him
Gojo states that well this was an
unlimited purple not bound by any
specific Target so it even damaged him
however as we can see it's obvious that
there's a difference in a level of their
damage Gojo assumes that it's just
because his curse energy pool is just
that large so in the end all's well that
ends well in his eyes he even jokes that
he totally crushed Kona and the
improvisation Department without use of
remote purple and that is the first time
his ever had to actually blow himself up
and then repair himself which again is
mental like how how do you even do that
I know like you can already see but as
long as you keep that part of the brain
there so I'm I'm imagining right now God
you blew his entire body up apart from
that one section of the brain and it
completely rehealed his body I don't
know man that's actually insane when you
think about it if you're confused like I
kind of am right here and how in the
world Goji was able to start using curse
energy again well it's like kusakabe
says here and how we all learned earlier
on back in the series when our boy Yuji
landed four of them Gojo was able to
regain his reverse curse technique
because of his use of black flashes so
you know like miracles happen when
people start Landing these black flashes
pretty much you know they they reach
their true potential and stuff so now
what's the Kona hope has slowed healing
no maharaga and an inability to do any
more damage without domain amplification
it means that for sure one hundred
percent Gojo wins the battle of the
strongest Sorcerer And the history of
the Jiu Jitsu Kaizen Universe however
that doesn't necessarily mean that this
fight actually comes to an end and
that's why and that's what I think a lot
of people don't necessarily realize here
I have no idea what's going to happen
next but I I just I know it's not ending
here we all know that sakuna has a box
with a bunch of tricks up a sleeve and
not a single sorcerer like apart from
obviously sukuna himself maybe even
kinjaku knows that he has this black box
technique speaking of the Black Box open
goju's incantation when he says the gap
between front and back or like within
and without corrects me if I'm wrong but
I'm pretty sure that that as a reference
to the curse Dimension itself I might be
completely wrong but like when I first
read through here and just thinking on
like all of the times he's used purple
now and like use implantations it
reminded me of zirconia's Black Box open
and gigay's one shot called number nine
and how it kind of explores this like
World of like Chicago armies and this
this dark world it's a really
interesting one show so I do recommend
reading it if you guys haven't because I
just have a feeling it's going to play
some parts in the story and how we
understand chickagami's in general
either way if you guys have enjoyed the
video then do leave a like as it really
really helps out with pushing my video
to a bunch of new amazing people and
subscribe if you are new around here to
keep getting these videos every single
week that we have this Gojo versus Kona
basil obviously you know check out my
chainsaw man video on the latest dating
dingy Arc if you guys missed that but
for now it's been your professional
degenerate dear Volo and I'll see you
all in eight Birds bye